Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep
have always loved the title of that
story by Philip K dick and it feels ever
more prescient today Do Androids Dream
of Electric Sheep we ask ourselves this
question as we increasingly grapple with
a world of synthetic intelligence where
more and more of our interactions are
happening with algorithms that seem to
exhibit some of the qualities of
awareness some of the qualities of
sentience it's the dawn of artificial
intelligence it's the dawn of a kind of
intelligence explosion and as we grapple
with the philosophical issues raised by
this encounter with a new kind of
mysterium tremendum a new kind of
synthetic mysterian tremendum we are
having to ask deep questions about what
it means to have a psyche what it means
to have an inner world what it means to
have theory of mind what it means to
have an inner psychology and so of
course Philip K dick was ahead of his
time when he asked the question to
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep you
know when Eric Davis wrote about the
spiritual cyborg in his book technosis
he wrestled with this very same thing we
are the spiritual cyborg we are the
thing that is a hybrid of biological and
non-biological intelligence we create
second skins and scaffoldings we are
increasingly merging with our tools and
Technologies but now we are spawning a
technology that talks back now we are
spawning a kind of artificial personhood
and we're interacting and engaging in a
feedback loop with that artificial
personhood and so again we should ask
this question we should get into a
platonic conversation about what this
means and where we're heading as we
increasingly Wonder to Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep through Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep